i'll tell you one of the most delightful
things about having an office in calif
uh in canada is
um we have many more employees there who
will stay longer for some reason
uh people in canada i think maybe
because we're you know maybe you don't
get to work for a venture capital firm
and live in canada there might not be
that many there so if you get to work
for us as a venture capital firm
well you'll stay with us longer because
there aren't a lot of options so the
loyalty goes up also they they have
their uh health care already taken care
of so we hire somebody there
and you have the dollar uh i think does
pretty well going to canada it might do
worse in other countries so you you do
have this like pluses and minuses in
each region i think it all nets out
basically the same the biggest win of
course is being able to fill a position
with a qualified person faster
um that's the big win i see across my
portfolios you know this oh my god we
need a product manager in los angeles
who's willing to go to the office in
downtown la
and it's like okay so that's one one
thousandth of the product managers in
the world
now we open it up to anywhere and it's
like okay now we have a thought we have
999 more candidates that we're going to
compete against we don't have to compete
against and if their
cost basis is lower too i don't know if
you're seeing this but i think payroll
was going to the moon in the bay area
and then all of a sudden it levels out
and in some cases has trended down on
average
which means you know you can not only
hire faster keep people longer but maybe
your costs went down 30 on average we
definitely see that and people there's a
lot of discussion around um i don't
really agree with this with people
talking existing companies lowering
people's salaries facebook said they
would do that yeah is doing it and i
think google's doing it too yeah i'm not
a huge fan of that because
i feel like if they were providing that
service and they were doing a good job
and all this kind of stuff and you're
kind of opening yourself up for poaching
and things like that but what we do see
is companies starting salaries for new
people that hire at lower dollar amounts
in other states and it's gonna kind of
you know over time raises and things
like that will balance things out but
you're right about the speed and also
like in canada especially the
engineering talent is phenomenal
and there's tax credits there yeah
people don't know about that yeah you
can get 100 tax credit for somebody
who's doing r d or 50
australia has that some you some
uh european union countries i think have
it so that's just another added benefit
yeah you know on the salary thing you
know i understand both sides of it i
think it's a really horrible thing to
have to execute
but here is the counter argument i'm
curious your thoughts on it
you and i started in austin texas
we were engineers at 125k you said oh
you know
the mother ship wants me to come work in
the valley
they know it's going to cost me
you know 50k more or 30k more in rent
they gave me a 30k bonus so now i'm
making you know whatever 30k more than
you and then i decided to go back to
austin after the pandemic and now we're
sitting next to each other and i get the
30k bonus and i get to keep it yeah
you're definitely right that is a
problem um it's just so tough because
the hiring environment is so
hot right now that there's this the the
classic like taking something away from
someone yeah always leaves you know it
creates some something freezing is the
way to do it yeah i think that's what
would be my thought is hey listen you
know we're paying people in canada this
we're paying people asking this you know
what that's all over
anybody who got paid a higher amount is
going to be frozen for the next three
years
sorry i know that's difficult anybody
else is going to get a little bit extra
and we're going to just try to make it
fair across the board that's actually
exactly what i recommend that's what i
would do is that the best practice yeah
it seems common sensical
um
but it's just hard to execute there's
bad feelings on both sides all three
sides of the table the person underpaid
the person overpaid and the company
having to to make this hard decision
yeah also reminding people sometimes
that they get to live
in a lower cost like all the other
non-monetary perks of living in wyoming
or montana they know it too like they
made that decision so i noticed when i
had that discussion with folks even at
our company like hey we're not coming
back to the office
and everybody was paid this you know
fees as if we were in the office and
people were paid differently i think
they get that they're like yeah i'm able
to afford a house i'm able to afford
half the my rent costs went down behalf
and i'm happy for people
to arbitrage it i don't need to do that
arbitrage zuckerberg doesn't need to do
that arbitrage but i think he's probably
yeah
he's zuckerberg yeah
yeah
some people can't let it go some people
can't i i'm letting it go